[Musique]
des milliers de gilet jaune ont envahi
les rues de grandes villes françaises
un an après le début de ce mouvement de
contestation j'en veux plus de ce
gouvernement on en a marre on dit à
maquereau on est là on est toujours là
les gili gens ne sont pas morts mais
dans plusieurs rassemblements
la situation a rapidement tourné au
vinaigre tirs de gaz lacrymogènes jets
de pierres véhicules renversés vitrines
fracassées poubelles incendiées les
dommages sont considérables
avant même le début de la marche le
préfet de paris a réagi j'ai décidé
d'interdire que cette manifestation se
déroule mais les gilets jaunes sont
demeurés sur les lieux et la tension a
monté les autorités ont procédé à des
dizaines d'arrestations et
d'interpellations auprès des
contestataires
des heurts ont aussi éclaté à nantes
lyon nice bordeaux et marseille entre
autres ce mouvement de contestation
populaire tire son origine d'une taxe
sur l'essence puis de la hausse globale
du coût de la vie d'un ras-le-bol
j'ai quatre enfants les changements sont
compliquées pour la première fois de ma
vie je me suis retrouvé à découvert à la
fin de votre ca mais jamais arrivé avant
j'aimais mes enfants je veux plus après
un an de mobilisation hebdomadaire les
gilets jaunes vise maintenant d'autres
stratégies pour obtenir des changements
ça fait un an qu'on reconnaît dans la
rue rien n'a changé vraiment faire autre
chose et on compte énormément sur le
mouvement de grève qui va avoir lieu le
5 décembre une grève reconductible qui
pourrait paralyser les transports en
france et ce à compter du 5 décembre
prochain
ici julie aimant radio canada montréal